A MOMENT.
WE WILL TALK ABOUT STATE OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY, INCLUDING WHAT
HE SAYS HE WOULD LIKE TO SEE FAR
LESS OF BECAUSE IN THE LAST 24
HOURS OR SO, IT AMOUNTS TO
PLENTY.
LATE-LAST NIGHT, WE LEARNED
WYOMING PARTY WILL NO LONGER
RECOGNIZE HER AS A MEMBER OF THE
GOP.
THAT'S AFTER HOUSE REPUBLICANS
IN WASHINGTON EARLIER-THIS YEAR
REMOVED HER FROM LEADERSHIP
OBVIOUSLY FOR DOING THE SAME.
LATE TODAY, BOTH WYOMING'S TWO
REPUBLICAN SENATORS DECLINED TO
SUPPORT CHENEY WHEN ASKED.
HOUSE DEMOCRATS ARE EXPECTED TO
LAUNCH CENSURE PROCEEDINGS
AGAINST CONGRESSMAN GOSAR
TOMORROW.
CONGRESSWOMAN CHENEY TODAY
CALLING KEVIN McCARTHY'S
INACTION ON GOSAR, QUOTE,
INDEFENSIBLE.
AS YOU KNOW, WHEN ASKED BY CNN
YESTERDAY, McCARTHY SAID HE HAD
CALLED GOSAR AND AFTERWARDS,
GOSAR REMOVED THE POST.
SAYING HE HAD THIS TO SAY OFF
CAMERA.
>> HE DIDN'T SEE IT BEFORE HE
POSTED AND TOOK IT DOWN.
IT WAS NOT HIS INTENT TO EVER
SHOW ANY HARM.
>> CONGRESSMAN McCARTHY ADDED
WHAT I SAID TO CONFERENCE WAS WE
CANNOT ACCEPT ANY SHOWING OF A
VIOLENCE TO ANY MEMBER.
MORE THAN A WEEK AFTER THE CLIP
WENT UP.
ADAM KINZINGER SAYING HE WILL
VOTE TOMORROW TO CENSURE GOSAR
BUT HE IS CERTAINLY IN A PRETTY
LONELY MINORITY.
PENNSYLVANIA CONGRESSMAN SCOTT
PERRY WHO HAS COME UNDER
SCRUTINY FOR HIS ROLE IN SEEKING
TO OVERTURN THE ELECTION.
SOME HEADLINES, PENNSYLVANIA
LAWMAKER PLAYED KEY ROLE IN
TRUMP'S PLOT TO OUST
ACTING-ATTORNEY GENERAL.
PA CONGRESSMAN SCOTT PERRY
ACKNOWLEDGES INTRODUCING TO
TRUMP TO LAWYER AT THE CENTER OF
ELECTION PLOT.
PENNSYLVANIA CONGRESSMAN AIDED
TRUMP EFFORT TO FLIP JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT ON BIG LIE.
NOW, IT SEEMS HE IS BEING
REWARDED FOR IT.
WE LEARNED AS WELL TODAY THE
WOMAN THE FORMER PRESIDENT
ENDORSED TO RUN ELECTIONS IN
MICHIGAN SPREAD FALSE-ELECTION
CLAIMS AND CONSPIRACY THEORIES
ABOUT JANUARY 6th.
IN PART, GOOD LUCK, CHRISTINA,
AND WHILE YOU ARE AT IT, CHECK
OUT THE FAKE ELECTION RESULTS
THAT TOOK PLACE IN THE CITY OF
DETROIT.
JUST FOR THE RECORD, THERE WAS
NO EVIDENCE OF ANY WIDESPREAD
FRAUD IN THE ELECTION.
BUT BELIEVING SUCH THING HAS
BECOME A PRICE OF ADMISSION FOR
REMAINING IN PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
GOOD GRACES, AS HAS DOWNPLAYING
THE VIOLENCE WE SAW AT THE
CAPITOL.
IT'S GOTTEN SO BAD FOR SOME
REPUBLICANS, THAT SIMPLY VOTING
FOR A BIPARTISAN BILL ON ROADS
AND BRIDGES HAS EARNED THEM
DEATH THREATS, AS WELL AS
EFFORTS BY FELLOW-PARTY MEMBERS
TO STRIP THEM OF COMMITTEE
ASSIGNMENTS.
THAT, TOO, IS TO CURRY FAVOR
WITH THE FORMER PRESIDENT WHO
OPPOSED THE BILL.
YET, THE IRONY IS THAT LOYALTY
ONLY SEEMS TO RUN ONE WAY.
IN HIS NEW BOOK, ABC'S JONATHAN
CARL RIGHTS ABOUT A CONVERSATION
THE FORMER PRESIDENT ALLEGEDLY
HAD IN HIS FINAL DAY AS
PRESIDENT WITH REPUBLICAN PARTY
CHAIR McDANIEL.
QUOTING NOW, I AM DONE.
TRUMP TOLD McDANIEL I AM
STARTING MY OWN PARTY.
YOU CANNOT DO THAT, McDANIEL
TOLD TRUMP.
IF YOU DO, WE WILL LOSE FOREVER.
QUOTE, EXACTLY.
YOU LOSE FOREVER WITHOUT ME,
TRUMP RESPONDED, I DON'T CARE.
JOINING US NOW, FORMER-NEW
JERSEY GOVERNOR CHRIS CHRISTIE.
AUTHOR OF "REPUBLICAN RESCUE,
SAVING THE PARTY FROM TRUTH
DENIERS, CONSPIRACY THEORISTS,
AND THE DANGEROUS POLICIES OF
JOE BIDEN."
CONGRATULATIONS ON THE BOOK.
>> THANK.
>> THE BOOK IS ABOUT, AS YOU SAY
RESCUING THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
DO YOU BELIEVE DONALD TRUMP
REALLY CARES ABOUT THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY?
>> WELL, THE BOOK IS NOT ABOUT
HIM.
ANDERSON.
IT'S ABOUT TALKING TO OUR VOTERS
ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND
SAYING TO THEM HOW ARE WE GOING
TO WIN AGAIN?
IN 2018 TO 2020, IN TWO YEARS,
WE LOST THE HOUSE, THE SENATE,
AND THE WHITE HOUSE.
THE ONLY OTHER TIME IN THE
150-PLUS-YEAR HISTORY OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY THAT HAPPENED
WAS HERBERT HOOVER FROM '30 TO
'32 AND THEN WE DIDN'T WIN THE
WHITE HOUSE AGAIN 28 OF THE NEXT
36 YEARS.
WE HAVE TO HAVE A VIABLE
TWO-PARTY SYSTEM IN THIS
COUNTRY.
WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO CONTRAST
DIFFERENT IDEAS.
GIVE VOTERS CHOICES.
AND TO DO THAT, WE HAVE TO, ONCE
AGAIN, BECOME THE PARTY OF
TRUTH.
>> THE PROBLEM, THOUGH, IS THE
FORMER PRESIDENT WHO IS THE HEAD
OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY NOW, ON
A NATIONAL LEVEL.
I MEAN, HE IS A TRUTH DENIER.
I MEAN, HE IS ONE OF THE PEOPLE
IN THE TITLE OF YOUR BOOK.
AND YET, YOUR PARTY IS BEHOLDEN
TO HIM.
>> WELL, LOOK.
I THINK THERE IS SOME THINGS YOU
ARE SEEING NOW, WHICH SHOW THAT
THAT'S BECOMING LESS SO.
YESTERDAY, THERE WAS A NEW POLL
FROM THE DES MOINES REGISTER OF
IOWA REPUBLICANS AND AS I KNOW
YOU KNOW, THOSE ARE SOME MOST
CONSERVATIVE REPUBLICANS IN
AMERICA, IN IOWA.
THEY ASKED A QUESTION, WHERE IS
YOUR FIRST LOYALTY?
TO THE REPUBLICAN PARTY?
OR TO DONALD TRUMP?
62% SAID THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
26% SAID DONALD TRUMP.
AND I THINK WE ARE IN AN
INSTANT-GRATIFICATION SOCIETY.
ANDERSON, DONALD TRUMP DOMINATED
THE POLITICAL WORLD IN THIS
COUNTRY, AND AROUND THE WORLD
FOR THAT MATTER, FOR FIVE YEARS.
HE'S BEEN GONE NOW NOT QUITE TEN
MONTHS OUT OF OFFICE.
AND WE EXPECT EVERYTHING TO BE
CHANGED.
I THINK THAT PEOPLE HAVE TO
START TO SPEAK OUT ABOUT THE
TRUTH, WHICH IS WHAT I TRY TO DO
IN THE BOOK.
>> BUT OTHER THAN, I MEAN, YOUR
SPEAKING OUT BUT THERE IS NOT A
LOT OF OTHER PEOPLE OUT THERE.
I MEAN, IT IS PRETTY LONELY W.
SEE WHAT HAPPENED TO LIZ CHENEY.
ADAM KINZINGER AS WELL SAID HE
IS NOT GOING TO RUN AGAIN.
>> WELL I THINK IT'S A LITTLE
DIFFERENT FOR ME BECAUSE, YOU
KNOW, FOR PEOPLE WHO SAY THEY
SUPPORT DONALD TRUMP, THEY HAVE
TO LINE UP BEHIND ME.
YOU REMEMBER I WAS THE FIRST ONE
TO ENDORSE HIM IN FEBRUARY OF
2016 AFTER I DROPPED OUT OF THE
RACE.
CHAIRED HIS TRANSITION.
WAS OFFERED CHIEF OF STAFF.
WAS OFFERED SECRETARY OF LABOR.
WAS OFFERED HOMELAND SECURITY
SECRETARY.
A LOT OF THINGS.
I DIDN'T TAKE THEM BUT I WAS
OFFERED THEM AND HELPED PREPARE
FOR BOTH SETS OF DEBATES.
>> DO YOU REGRET THAT SUPPORT?
>> I DON'T BECAUSE AS I SAID TO
THE BRITISH AMBASSADOR ONE DAY,
ANDERSON, THE WAY AMERICA WORKS
IS YOU DON'T ALWAYS GET TO VOTE
FOR WHO YOU WANT TO.
YOU GET TO VOTE FOR WHO'S LEFT
IN OUR SYSTEM.
SO, IN 2016, I RAN AGAINST HIM.
I WASN'T SUCCESSFUL.
>> 2016, YOU SAID THERE IS NO
ONE WHO IS BETTER PREPARED TO
PROVIDE AMERICA WITH THE STRONG
LEADERSHIP IT NEEDS, BOTH A HOME
AND AROUND THE WORLD, THAN
DONALD TRUMP.
IN OUR RNC SPEECH, YOU SAID WE
ARE ABOUT TO BE LED BY NOT ONLY
A STRONG LEADER BUT BY A CARING,
GENUINE, AND DECENT PERSON.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT?
NOW?
>> WELL, LOOK, I THINK WHAT I
SAID THERE, I ABSOLUTELY
BELIEVED THAT HE WAS OUR
STRONGEST OPTION THAT WAS LEFT
WHEN I SAID THOSE THINGS.
UM, AND -- AND THE FACT IS THAT,
AGAIN, YOU ARE LEFT WITH THE
CHOICES YOU HAVE.
BUT NOW, WHAT I AM SAYING TO
FOLKS IS --
>> DO YOU BELIEVE THAT HE WAS
CARING, GENUINE, AND A DECENT
PERSON?
>> LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING.
WHEN I SAID THOSE THINGS, HE HAD
ALWAYS BEEN THAT TO ME AT THAT
TIME.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE THAT NOW?
>> WELL, HE'S BEEN LESS OF THAT
TO ME OVER THE COURSE OF TIME.
BUT I STILL CONSIDER HIM A
FRIEND.
WE HAVE BEEN FRIENDS FOR 20
YEARS.
>> BUT DO YOU THINK HE HAS BEEN
DECENT, DO YOU THINK HE HAS BEEN
GENUINE AND CARING?
WHEN YOU WERE IN THE HOSPITAL,
HE CALLED YOU UP AND HE WAS
SAYING SOMETHING ABOUT LIKE YOU
ARE NOT GOING TO SAY YOU GOT IT
FROM ME, ARE YOU?
>> BUT FROM THAT CONVERSATION,
HE DID ASK HOW I WAS DOING.
BUT THE FACT IS, ANDERSON, IS
THAT WITH HAS FALLEN DOWN IN MY
VIEW MOST STARKLY AND THE PART I
EMPHASIZE IN THE BOOK THE MOST
IS FROM ELECTION NIGHT FORWARD.
AND I SAID ON TELEVISION THAT
NIGHT RIGHT AFTER HIS SPEECH
THAT YOU CAN'T STAND BEHIND THE
PRESIDENT AND THE EAST ROOM OF
THE WHITE HOUSE AND TELL THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THE ELECTION WAS
STOLEN WHEN YOU HAVE NO EVIDENCE
TO PROVE THAT IT WAS.
>> BUT YOU WON'T SAY THAT PERSON
SHOULD NEVER BE ABLE TO STAND
BEHIND THE PODIUM IN THE WHITE
HOUSE, AGAIN.
>> THIS IS NOT MY CHOICE WHETHER
HE STANDS BEHIND IT.
AND I HAVE LEARNED OVER TIME
THAT ALL YOU CAN DO IS DO WHAT
YOU DO AND WHAT I AM DOING
NOW --
>> YOU WOULD HAVE THE CHOICE OF
VOTING FOR HIM OR NOT AND YOU
WON'T SAY -- OR WOULD YOU SAY
YOU --
>> NO BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW WHAT
MY ALTERNATIVES WILL BE,
ANDERSON.
AND -- AND, YOU KNOW, SO IT'S
BAD AT THIS POINT AND WRONG TO
GET INTO SPECULATION ABOUT THAT.
>> IT'S NOT SPECULATION.
>> NO, IT IS.
>> CHANCE HE IS GOING TO RUN.
AND OBVIOUSLY, YOU --
>> I AM NOT SO SURE OF THAT.
>> EVERYBODY HAS TO MAKE A
CHOICE.
AND YOU KNOW -- GIVEN WHO ELSE
THERE MAY BE, YOU KNOW WHAT HE
IS.
YOU THINK HE IS STILL CAPABLE.
>> WELL, I DON'T KNOW WHO ELSE
WILL BE MY CHOICE AND I THINK
UNTIL YOU KNOW THAT, IT IS
IRRESPONSIBLE TO SAY WHO YOU
WOULD PICK OR WHO YOU WOULDN'T
PICK.
>> SO YOU -- BUT YOU DON'T THINK
SUPPORTING THE ATTACK ON THE
CAPITOL, FOMENTING THE
INSURRECTION, IS A DISQUALIFIER?
>> WHAT I SAID IN THE BOOK WAS
THAT HE HAS TO TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THAT.
AND -- AND I BELIEVE EVERYBODY
SHOULD HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CHANGE THEIR MINDS.
>> RIGHT.
>> AND TO APOLOGIZE FOR THINGS.
>> BUT YOU KNOW HE IS NOT GOING
TO APOLOGIZE.
>> I DON'T KNOW THAT.
LOOK, I CAN'T PREDICT WHAT HE
WILL DO BUT WHAT I'M DOING IS
LAYING OUT FOR PEOPLE VERY
CLEARLY.
>> HAS HE EVER APOLOGIZED FOR
ANYTHING?
>> YES.
YES.
I REMEMBER HIM APOLOGIZING FOR,
UM, THE STATEMENTS HE MADE ON
THE MEXICAN JUDGE.
UM, DURING THE PRIMARY.
UM, AND -- AND -- SO THAT'S ONE
INSTANCE THAT I CAN REMEMBER
RIGHT OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD.
BUT WHAT -- WHAT'S MORE
IMPORTANT TO ME IS THAT OUR --
THAT OUR VOTERS, OUR CITIZENS
HAVE TO LOOK AT WHAT THE FACTS
WERE AND THE WAY I TRIED TO
WRITE THIS BOOK REGARDING NOT
ONLY THE ELECTION BUT A NUMBER
OF THESE OTHER CONSPIRACY AND
TRUTH-DENYING THINGS LIKE QANON
OR PIZZAGATE OR BIRTHERISM WAS
APPROACH IT LIKE A PROSECUTOR.
SAY LISTEN, EVERYBODY.
HERE IS THE ALLEGATION, HERE IS
ALL THE FACTS.
>> BUT AGAIN, ALL OF THOSE ARE
THINGS THE PRESIDENT HAS EITHER
BEEN, HIMSELF, A BIRTHER, TRUTH
DENIER.
HE'S CERTAINLY, YOU KNOW, PLAYED
A -- A -- COY WITH QANON, AT THE
VERY LEAST.
HE'S BEEN OPENLY ENCOURAGING.
>> I LAY OUT THAT CASE IN THE
BOOK.
LOOK.
WHAT I AM TRYING TO DO,
ANDERSON -- AND THIS IS THE KIND
OF THE WAY -- THE WRONG WAY SOME
PEOPLE APPROACH THE VACCINE
ISSUE, IN MY VIEW.
THEY TRY TO TELL PEOPLE, THIS IS
IT.
YOU MUST DO THIS.
WHAT I AM SAYING IS YOU NEED TO
EDUCATE PEOPLE.
YOU NEED TO EDUCATE THEM, NOT
INDOCTRINATE THEM.
SO WHAT I TRY TO DO IN THE BOOK
IS LAY OUT FOR PEOPLE IN A VERY
PLAIN-SPOKEN, FACTUAL WAY.
I SAW THIS STATEMENT IN YOUR
LEAD WHERE YOU SAID ABOUT THE
ERRONEOUS OR FAKE RESULTS IN
DETROIT.
WELL, I LAY OUT IN THE BOOK VERY
SPECIFICALLY THAT HE ACTUALLY
DID BETTER IN DETROIT IN 2020
THAN HE DID IN 2016.
AND JOE BIDEN ACTUALLY DID WORSE
THAN HILLARY CLINTON DID.
THAT'S A VERY INEFFECTIVE THEFT
IF YOU ARE GOING TO LET THE
OTHER GUY DO BETTER.
>> THERE WERE A LOT OF
REPUBLICANS WHO DID VERY WELL IN
THE ELECTION DOWN BALLOT, JUST
HE DIDN'T.
>> THAT IS ALSO IN THE BOOK AS
WELL BUT I AM TALKING DETROIT IN
PARTICULAR.
>> THE THING IS, THOUGH, YOU
KNOW, THE REPUBLICAN -- I MEAN,
I AGREE WITH YOU, AS A
CITIZEN -- STEPPING ASIDE AS A
REPORT ISSUE -- AS A CITIZEN, I
WANT THERE TO BE TWO STRONG,
VIABLE PARTIES THAT HAVE
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES AND
BATTLE IT OUT BUT THAT HAVE A
BASIC AGREEMENT OF WHAT IS TRUTH
AND WHAT IS NOT AND THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY, TODAY, SEEMS
TO HAVE GIVEN UP ON THAT,
LARGELY -- I MEAN, YOU LOOK AT
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN CONGRESS.
THESE PEOPLE ARE TERRIFIED OF
HIM.
>> WELL, LOOK.
I THINK ALSO THERE HAVE BEEN
TIMES WHEN WE COULD SEE THE SAME
THING ABOUT THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
AND -- AND WHAT CHANGES THAT?
LEADERS COME FORWARD AND SAY,
NO, NO, HERE IS THE BETTER WAY.
AND WHAT I'M SAYING IN THIS BOOK
AND I HAVE BEEN SAYING IN A
SPEECH THAT THE PRESIDENT
CRITIQUED AT THE REPUBLICAN
JEWISH COALITION LAST WEEKEND OR
IN SEPTEMBER IS THAT WE HAVE TO
BE THE PARTY NOW THAT'S TALKING
ABOUT TOMORROW AND NOT ABOUT
YESTERDAY BECAUSE GRIEVANCE
POLITICS, VENDETTA POLITICS
ABOUT AN ELECTION THAT IS LONG
OVER NOW, UM, IS NOT THE WAY TO
SHOW YOU'RE A LEADER.
UM, AND -- AND I WANT TO SHOW
OUR PARTY THERE IS A WAY TO DO
THIS.
AND BY THE WAY, GLENN YOUNGKIN
AND JACK CIATTARELLI DID IT.